hello welcome to our kitchen
uh-oh you see the fly kill this fly for
me my name is andrew you might recognize
me from the show worth it where i'm
usually tasting foods at different price
points with my pals steven and adam i'm
going to be recreating one of my
favorite dishes
i ever had on worth it chocolate salami
in our lasagna episode we ate at
yes so in our lasagna episode we ate at
pasta sisters
and after eating their amazing lasagna
my worth at winter they shared their
chocolate salami with us which turns out
to be
a simple dessert of chocolate formed
around
broken up bits of cookies that ends up
resembling
a salami i think making this recipe will
help me explore something that i'm
really interested in
which is fundamentals of why something
tastes
good holy sh with chocolate salami i
think it's an amazing example
of deliciousness in simplicity it's just
a couple of ingredients but
when combined they transform into
something
exciting and intriguing and so much more
than the sum of its parts so to learn a
little bit more about this recipe i'm
going to be speaking with francesco
and georgia to see how the salami's made
i guess hey guys how are you
good you're great since the last time
you came to visit us
we also opened pasta sister food truck
we are
bringing around town our pasta and we
share also the chocolate salami
on the truck it's such an interesting
dessert i'd never heard of this
chocolate salami before it's mostly a
family
tradition it's mostly done by grandmas
and moms i think it was invented in a
way that you had a bunch of stuff at
home
you just put it together and every
family has a different recipe for this
reason my
grandmother was like just
straightforward cookies
eggs and chocolate and sugar so
my mom just is actually giving me
my grandma book it's this one the recipe
wow so the cookies are crumbled inside
and when you cut it in slices
the cookies recreate the fat of the
salami seems like it's a dessert that
you can just keep in the freezer
and whenever you are hungry you just go
you cut a slice and you eat it
thank you so much for sharing this
recipe with me it was really fun talking
to you guys
it was a pleasure to see you again okay
i've picked up the ingredients
based on the pasta sister's
recommendation i'm going to use
mcvitty's digestive wheat biscuits and
leibniz butter biscuits i've always
wanted to know why these are called
digestives
do they truly help with digestion
oh it's graham cracker it smells the
same as graham cracker
or maybe it's that graham cracker smells
like these
[Music]
i mean i like them because they're very
boring tasting but i could also see why
your first instinct would be to add some
chocolate to this and now
our german butter cookies butter kicks
they're nice yeah so the first task is
to take some of these
biscuits and break them up
i guess i just smack them right
how hard do you beat a biscuit also
i'm gonna be calling these biscuits even
though i'm more used to saying cookie
i'm gonna be calling them biscuits
because that's what they call themselves
i feel like i'm creating a lot of fine
biscuit sand here
um but still some of my pieces are are a
little bit too big
i'm trying to picture this inside of the
chocolate salami
okay i'm gonna stop right there i feel
like
[Applause]
in the pasta sisters version you get a
clear
outline of a biscuit i don't want to go
too far
there's something about these biscuits
that's like it's not too tasty
it's interesting not too tasty
is the right amount of tasting something
to think about
okay next up i'm going to prep the
chocolate i feel like
when you're doing this type of recipe
where it's just chocolate and biscuits
you want to get a good
chocolate
it looks like freaking gold
god damn it chocolate is so good
chocolate's one of those foods where you
taste it and you're like
yeah i don't need anything more than
that i'm basically shaving this down
into little shards
i don't know if this sounds silly but
when chocolate is really good
you kind of get the sense that it comes
from a plant
well i could shave chocolate all day
okay now that there is chocolate
approximately everywhere
we can move on to the next step so this
wasn't a requirement but they happened
to have italian butter
in the grocery store and i thought how
fun oh yeah
look at that
[Music]
that's delicious okay 100 grams of
butter i'm going to melt this very
quickly
two egg yolks i love
separating egg yolks it's like the most
tenderest form of surgery you could do
100
grams of sugar whisk this together
melted butter
i'm also going to add jamaican dark rum
adding the chocolate now
[Music]
i don't think i chopped my chocolate
fine enough i guess i'll just have a
more
rustic salami lastly
this looks terrible i don't think i did
a good job with this
this looks nothing like their photos
this just doesn't look
like it has the right consistency this
needs to get in the freezer because it's
quickly becoming way too
melty okay this salami has been in the
freezer overnight there it is
my freezer salami oh why is mine so bad
i mean it smells incredible immediately
i can tell
i did not do nearly as clean of a job as
they do at pasta sisters the one that we
had was a perfect dark chocolate
exterior you know the more i look at it
really does
resemble meat here we go
i am now so confused how they make it
so nicely i don't understand
because my mixture is so uneven as i'm
going through it some different areas
look
better than others i'm just gonna go to
the direct
center of my salami it's so weird to say
my salami but i guess this is like
the easiest recipe that you get to say
that my salami
i made a salami i really should have
prioritized
the larger sections of biscuit because
they're the sections that most resemble
chunks of fat that you see in
real meat salami
[Music]
i mean yeah how could it not taste good
it's extremely satisfying for
a coin sized slice of dessert it is
exploding
with flavor it is so good i think there
are a lot of different
levels of dessert you could have a
single hershey kiss or you have a slice
of wedding cake where the chocolate
salami lives
is my personal favorite just a
satisfying
single morsel how do i think i did not
really good
i mean this is classic mom and grandma
type recipe
the ingredient list is short the
technique explanation is short but to
get it good
like you need the experience in your
hands to do it really well
if you want actually great chocolate
salami as well as some delicious pasta
please visit pasta sisters you know what
else it is
it's a reverse chocolate chip cookie
[Music]
you